CHAD JENNINGS: Hi, everyone.
My name is Chad, and
thanks for joining us.
And today we're going to
talk about reinventing
geospatial analytics,
and I'm joined today
by Joe Bettridge from TELUS.
And the key point
of this talk is
going to be to describe what
becomes available to users
and customers and their users
when you really take the brakes
off geospatial analytics.
JOE BETTRIDGE: Hi, there.
I'm Joe Bettridge.
I lead the TELUS Insights
consulting program at TELUS.
We are a heavy user
of Google BigQuery
as well as BigQuery GIS.
CHAD JENNINGS: Right on.
And Joe and I are both
excited to show you
what we've been up to.
So here are the two of us.
We're your speakers.
I'm a product
manager at BigQuery,
and I'm also the GIS
lead for Google Cloud.
JOE BETTRIDGE: And I am
the consulting practice
lead for TELUS Insights.
CHAD JENNINGS: Right on.
OK, so without further ado,
let's go ahead and get into it.
We'll talk about
use cases, and Joe
is going to go through
some of the algorithms
that TELUS is using
inside of BigQuery GIS.
But to set that up, I'm going
to go through a couple--
call it terms of art.
We're going to go through
BigQuery just a little bit
and what BigQuery GIS
is, and then we're
going to get into
some more detail.
So if you already are very
familiar with the product,
put me on 1 and 1/2 times speed
for the next minute and a half.
So with that, let's jump in.
For those not familiar, BigQuery
is Google Cloud's enterprise
data warehouse.
So looking at the left
side of the screen here,
we're primarily
an analytics tool,
and the product's
real claim to fame
here is that we can scale
from gigabytes to petabytes
without encumbering the
user with having to manage
any of that infrastructure.
You interact with
the product in SQL,
so it essentially looks
like a relational database
that can scale up to petabytes.
Data inside of BigQuery
is encrypted, durable,
and the product is
highly available.
As a matter of fact, we
just launched four nines
of availability as
our new SLA, which
is industry leading,
which is really cool.
We want to make the product
as differentiated and useful
to users as possible, so we
have a couple of unique items
that I wanted to talk about.
The fact that BigQuery is
fully managed and serverless,
those are the things
that enable us
to scale to petabytes without
making users provision hardware
and things of that nature.
We have a real-time
streaming API
so you can stream data
straight into BigQuery.
And then using the
BI engine, which
is on the bottom
of the list here,
you can actually query
that in real time.
So you can do real-time
insights on data
streamed right into
your data warehouse
without having to
use any other tools.
We've also invented
some new SQL verbs
so that you can do
machine learning right
inside the platform.
And what this talk is all
about is some other SQL verbs.
We didn't invent them.
We're using the PostGIS syntax.
But by bringing geospatial SQL
functions and geospatial data
types into BigQuery,
we're enabling
a whole new class of use
cases inside the product.
So let's dive in.
What is BigQuery GIS?
First and foremost, it's
supporting a new geography data
type.
We launched this to alpha a
couple of years ago in 2018.
It's since gone GA.
So this is a very solid
offering inside the product.
And a geography data
type, as you can see,
can have several
different shapes.
Points, line, strings,
polygons, multis, collections,
all of these fit inside
the geography data type.
To operate on those
data types, we
have a number of
different functions.
So we've got about 50 or
so PostGIS syntax functions
that we've implemented
inside of BigQuery,
and these function types
take the categories here.
And they cover the
primary and the majority
of the functionality that
folks use inside of PostGIS.
What's really exciting
about some of these,
though, is that
particularly the predicates,
you can do geospatial
joins based on predicates.
So if you want to
join two tables based
on whether a point
is inside a polygon,
that is totally within bounds.
If you want to do that on
data sets that are really big,
like terabytes or
hundreds of terabytes,
that also is totally
within bounds.
And Joe is going to
talk a little bit more
about what becomes possible
when those limits are
relaxed for your workloads.
Speaking of workloads, almost
any analytics workload,
whether it's geospatial or
not, has these components.
First thing, you need to
get data into your product
or into the data warehouse.
So that's the ingest here.
Then you have to analyze it
inside the data warehouse.
And then results as a table
are interesting for some result
sets, I suppose, but really
you want to visualize that.
And particularly
for geospatial, you
want to visualize
those on a map.
And so I wanted
to call these out
because there are some aspects
here that BigQuery and BigQuery
GIS are really
struggling at, and there
are some places where we need
our partner tools to really
flesh out these workflows.
So I'm going to go through
from left to right.
So in ingest, BigQuery has a
load API and a streaming API.
And so if you want to--
a lot of our, for example,
industrial IoT customers
are using the streaming API
to stream instrument or sensor
data straight into
BigQuery tables.
We have customers
using the BigQuery load
API to load as much
as a petabyte per day,
and we have customers
using the streaming API
to load up to 10 gigabytes
per second per table.
So that handles data
that we would just
want to flow straight
in, but let's say
you have data sets that are in
specific geospatial formats.
For that, we've partnered
with Safe Software,
and they have written a BigQuery
emitter for their tool FME.
This tool allows you to import
and materializes a BigQuery
table any number of the
hundreds of geospatial formats
that they support.
So if you've got shapefiles
or KML or GeoJSON
or what have you--
geospatial data format X--
chances are FME
supports it, and you
can bring that straight in
using a drag-and-drop tool
into BigQuery.
So ingest, cool stuff.
Now, the real
strength of BigQuery
shows up in this Analyze
column in that BigQuery,
as I mentioned before, the
strength of this product
is that it can process
data at the petabyte scale.
And so when you add
geospatial analysis to this,
you can now process GIS
data at the petabyte scale,
which really hasn't
been possible before.
And so this type
of data, I'm really
talking about structured
and semistructured data.
For imagery data, we have to
turn to tools like Google Earth
Engine and Descartes
Labs, and I'll
talk about those in a little
bit more detail later.
So once you've
done your analysis,
let's move on to
serve and visualize.
Particularly with
geospatial analyses,
you don't look at a table.
You want to see your
results on a map.
And we have a multitude of
tools, some of them specified
for different personas or
different types of users
to put those results in
a map and then serve them
either as a report or
as a portal or just
as an image for an analyst.
The ones I've
highlighted here in bold
are ones that have direct
connectors to BigQuery.
So you don't have to extract a
file and then transform a file
and then render it.
So there's a healthy selection
of folks that connect directly
to BigQuery.
So let's talk about a couple
of these tools in detail.
First off, let's talk
about Google Earth Engine
as it performs on
imagery analytics.
So Earth Engine is a
tool, a product at Google.
It's been around
for about 10 years,
and it has an immense data
catalog of satellite imagery,
and it's about 30 petabytes.
And the thing that's really
cool about their data catalog
is that when new satellite
imagery comes in,
Earth Engine as a service
will automatically
register and
orthorectify that imagery
so that it is includable
in your analysis
with a single line of code.
So for example, like
#include for those
that speak C, #include sentinel
imagery from this date, date A.
And boom, that's
it, and now you've
got the entire globe of
sentinel imagery from that date.
You can then include
central imagery from date B
to do an A/B comparison,
again with just a couple lines
of code.
Very cool stuff.
Descartes Labs is another
image-processing tool that
connects directly to BigQuery.
They themselves have an
immense data catalog,
and some of these thumbnails
here describe elements of it--
for example, like SAR imagery,
AIS, which is automatic--
actually, I've forgotten
the acronym to that,
but that one's actually ship
positions showing shipping
lanes all over the world.
They also have a
dedicated solutions team.
So if there's an aspect of this
data that you want to process
and you need some
support, Descartes Labs
has a lot of detailed
expertise to help you along.
So the next few slides, we're
going to step in and kind of
go persona by persona.
So analysts-- if you're
an analyst, you speak SQL.
You're using BigQuery.
You look in the documentation.
You figure out which
ST commands you need,
and you write your query.
And you just want
to see those results
on a map to understand
what your results are.
BigQuery Geo Viz is an
excellent tool for that.
So you can either write
the query in the UI,
and then there's a dropdown
where you can explore it
directly in Geo Viz.
You can compose your query
in the Geo Viz window, which
then runs it against BigQuery.
And then that allows you then
to do interactive styling
and visualization, pan and zoom.
This is all on top
of Google Maps.
We've also done a
bunch of upgrades
to this little product
over the last few months.
So we've blown away the
visualization limitations.
And so it's essentially that
you can render as many points
as your browser can hold.
And we've enabled the ability
to share maps with colleagues.
So this is not a full-featured
geospatial-analysis platform.
Like I said, it's a way to
get your query on a screen
so you can understand it.
But it's a handy little tool
that we like quite a lot.
So for developers,
BigQuery GIS is also
supported by the
Google Maps API.
So you can bring BigQuery
data straight into your map
applications and
map visualizations.
So you can see here
this is actually a heat
map of taxi trips in Manhattan.
So that center image is
the island of Manhattan.
And then the API has
some really nifty ways
to call out specific areas,
which are shown in the two
images on the right.
Now, business users--
if you're not an analyst
and you're not a
developer and you just
want to operate in a
BI tool, again, we've
got you covered here.
Both Data Studio and Looker have
support for BigQuery GIS types
or BigQuery geography types.
And so you can use these tools
to create dashboards on top
of pan-and-zoomable maps.
Now, one element that we
haven't touched on yet
that I'm very excited
to announce today right
now in this section
is the Carto Tiler.
With BigQuery, you
have the ability
to process enormous
volumes of data.
The tools that I've shown you
before are very, very capable,
but they don't have the ability
to render the same level
and same magnitude of volumes
of data that BigQuery can.
And Carto, our partner,
has solved that.
And what they've done
with the Carto Tiler
is they've created
a way to create
a hierarchy of data that's
corresponding to zoom levels
here.
So what you're seeing
in the right image
is the building locations pulled
from the OpenStreetMap data
set, which incidentally
is available in BigQuery
public data.
So you can create
this map as well.
And there are 300 million
dots worldwide on this map.
And so if we click
into that map,
you can see how fluid and
detailed the rendering
is as you go from street level
all the way back out to orbit.
And again, we're
announcing the availability
of Carto's beta today.
There are some links over
here on the left-hand side.
So you can play with
this map yourself,
And there's an
email address there
for you to send a note to
to get more information.
So just in case you thought
the Carto Tiler only
worked on points, here's
an example on polygons.
So we're going to zoom
in here again on New York
where the southwest corner has
some really interesting-shaped
apartment buildings.
So the links here are on the
slide on the bottom left,
and we are very excited to
announce this with our partner
Carto as now visualization
can approach the same scale
as BigQuery's native compute.
So very exciting stuff.
Thank you.
The last section before
I hand it off to Joe
is I wanted to talk at a high
level about the use cases
that we are seeing our
customers employ BigQuery GIS.
So starting on the
left-hand side,
in retail, the primary
operations in retail that we've
seen are channel
optimization, site selection,
and marketing analysis
by trade area.
Because BigQuery allows you
to define your own polygons
obviously, you can define your
own data-driven trade areas
rather than using
the established ones
like either census blocks or
zip codes or any other kind
of established polygon.
You can define your own that
are specific to your business's
needs and then run whatever
aggregations you need,
again because the
scale will support you.
In supply chain and
logistics, we've
seen a number of our
customers use IoT,
so Internet of Things, data
to do traffic analysis, which
is what this image shows.
This is actually a heat map of
ML-predicted hazardous driving
areas developed by our
partner and customer Geotab.
So they actually
used vehicular data
combined with
weather data that's
already stored in BigQuery to
do a GIS plus machine learning
tool to say you can dial
in a weather condition
and then have that predict what
the hazardous driving would
be for that weather condition.
So very useful for city
planners and traffic planners.
We see a lot of activity
around delivery optimization
and, really gratifyingly,
we're seeing
some significant projects around
supply-chain sustainability.
So this is calculating the
human cost, the economic cost,
and the environmental
cost of taking product
from its source, which may be
many, many thousands of miles
away from its ultimate
destination on the shelf
before you buy it.
And so knowing the true
costs of that supply chain
and being able to optimize
that supply chain to make it
economically,
environmentally sustainable
is really exciting work.
We all know how important
public dissemination of data
is in this time and
age, and so we've
seen a number of US states
and countries around the world
use BigQuery GIS and
our dashboarding tools
to support public data portals.
Also very interestingly,
this is an air-quality map
from our colleagues
at Aclima and Geotab
where they're actually
discovering, one,
that air quality can change
on a block-by-block basis
and, two, that the reduction in
human travel during these COVID
times has greatly reduced
the pollutants in the air.
And they have a lot of research
that they've used BigQuery
and BigQuery GIS to support.
And then lastly in
agriculture, we've
seen a lot of usage
around yield optimization,
so trying to get the most
food production out of a field
that you possibly can.
And then once you've figured
it out for the field,
because these tools,
BigQuery and, in this case,
Earth Engine operate
at such scale,
you can do these analyses for
the entire globe in one shot.
And so that way S4 Agtech,
another one of our customers,
is doing worldwide
production forecasting.
Figuring out how much grain
the Ukraine is going to do
is just one step
of their process
because they can do that for
the Ukraine, for Argentina,
the entire globe in one shot.
So with that, let me
wrap up my section.
I've given you a very
high-level introduction
to both BigQuery, BigQuery
GIS, and some of the partner
ecosystem and use cases.
And I'd like to
hand it over to Joe
now to tell you what
TELUS is doing in detail.
JOE BETTRIDGE: Perfect.
Thank you for that, Chad.
So just to get us started,
for those of you who are not
from Canada and don't
know who TELUS is,
TELUS is one of the largest
telecommunication companies
within Canada.
So we represent about
9 and 1/2 million
of the 35 million Canadians
on their cellular plans.
And one of the things we've
been doing for the last while is
we've been developing an
insights product that allows us
to use massive amounts of
deidentified aggregate data
to answer really complex
questions about the real world,
and what we want
to announce today
is that we're creating an
API into this data that
is launching today that
allows for users to query
this data directly and
get aggregate results back
that have no individual
information in them
but can answer really
complex business problems.
This is a first for
us, and it's one
of the first times in
the world that an API
of this type of data has
been able to be generated,
and that's thanks
to BigQuery GIS.
So the big picture of
what we're trying to do
is we're trying to solve the
problem that many businesses
have today of making
critical decisions based
on gut feel, small-sample-rate
surveys, and straw-men business
cases.
We had this promise of big
data for a very long time,
yet we haven't seen a
lot of delivery on it.
We've just seen mass and mass
amounts of data be stored,
but no real analysis has
been capable to be completed
that can really
solve the questions
that businesses and
governments have.
Usually this is for
one of two reasons.
Either the technology is
a roadblock or privacy
has been a roadblock.
As I'll talk about in
the next few slides,
both of these things
have been solved
using both BigQuery and the
previous groundwork we've
laid around privacy.
And we need this to be scalable.
This is a really critical issue.
Government's existing
BI tools need
to be integrated and
need to be able to be
used within the current
supply chain of data.
We can't be trying to
create a new set of tools.
We need integration
directly to the tools today.
As Chad was talking to
earlier, the BigQuery GIS
is really great for plugging
into a lot of different tools
that we commonly use.
So what is TELUS Insights?
TELUS Insights takes all
the aggregate information
being generated by
our cellular network.
So every time a phone
connects to a cell tower,
there's a residual
event that's created
that says this phone was at
this cell tower at this time.
We take all that information
across the country.
We remove all the identifiers.
We get rid of anything
that's personal from that,
and we create a
row-level record saying
this is the data of what
happened across Canada.
We then upload that
data into the cloud,
process it, remove a lot of the
secondary information that's
not necessary, and then we
start analyzing it and producing
insights.
These insights
could be that there
were 10,000 people in the
neighborhood at a time that
spent at least two days
there in the last week.
It could be the trade area
of a given business, maps
around a certain area.
The primary area of trade
is within five kilometers
of the business.
The secondary area is within
seven kilometers to the east
and only three
kilometers to the west.
We're able to pull this all
out and aggregate that through.
And finally, we're
doing these results
through an API that's
powered by Google Cloud.
In all of this, we need privacy.
Privacy is a critical
cornerstone of everything
we do around Insights.
TELUS has worked very closely
with Ann Cavoukian, who's
the former privacy
commissioner of Ontario,
on achieving Privacy by
Design certification.
This certification
entails ensuring
that all privacy and
regulatory issues are met.
The language she wrote
has influenced the GDPR
and has been seen
there throughout.
What we do specifically is
we add in privacy controls,
including deidentification.
So before we analyze any
data, we're deidentifying it.
We aggregate all
of our information
into large data pools.
So we don't allow anything
about individuals or even
small groups of individuals.
Further to this, we
extrapolate all the data
to match to our market share.
So it represents the entirety
of the country as opposed
to only TELUS's share.
We also include
security within this.
We do a lot of work
on security and making
sure this product
is secure by design.
All engagements
beyond this are also
audited by our trust model.
TELUS views trust as a
cornerstone of all privacy.
If you don't have trust,
you can't have privacy.
And how we gain trust is
through being transparent.
So we update our
privacy policies
to include what we're doing
with deidentified and aggregate
data.
We also understand that
not a lot of people
read privacy policies,
so one of the things
we've done to help this
is we've added privacy
frequently asked questions
on our website that
are written in very
plain and simple language
that help everyone understand
exactly what we are doing.
And finally, we
give users control.
So we give users the
ability to opt out
of any of these
large-scale analyses
without asking them for
reasoning or justification.
It's just a simple opt-out
if they choose to do so.
With this being said,
I'm going to take you
through our architecture
very briefly
and talk through a bit of
what we do specifically
with the data.
So all of this data is captured
with probes within our network.
I'm not going to go into
detail about how that works.
But once that data is
landed on a server,
it's pushed out to
Google Cloud using NiFi.
Once it lands there, it's
put into a Dataflow job,
and that Dataflow job removes
all the opted-out information.
It sanitizes and deidentifies.
It strips out all the personally
identifiable information
from the data, and then
it does some analysis
to retain secondary traits.
So that data [INAUDIBLE] could
be things like area codes
or the country of origin
of the device that
are stored in that
personal information
but are not the
entirety of that data.
Once all of this has
been stripped down
to the skeleton of
the information,
it's landed into BigQuery
where further analysis
is done to remove things
like duplicate devices,
undesirable devices.
These might be things
like roaming devices
from an IoT device
that's not actually part
of what we're
looking to analyze.
As well as we generate a
system-based universal unique
identifier.
So this identifier is
generated by the system.
It's the only
identifier associated
with any of the information
from this point forward,
meaning there's
no tie back to any
of the personal information.
Once this is done,
our data is pushed
through to an analysis layer.
At this layer, we do a
lot of different work
to reduce the amount of
data that we're storing.
This includes collapsing
down each device
into a timeline of what happened
to that device as opposed
to all the individual events.
We also calculate an assumed
home and work neighborhood.
We'll talk a bit more
about how that works
and how we preserve privacy in
that step on the next slide.
We also then include a geo
ID to each location which
is used to apply market share.
And finally, we compute
all of our API queries
against this
aggregated data set.
So our final layer
is our output layer.
And this layer is
built in App Engine,
and it allows users to
query and asks things
like what are the number
of visitors in a given
polygon at a given time?
And they get a
result returned back
from that from the
analysis layer.
All of these results meet
our privacy thresholds
and are about large
aggregate groups.
We'll talk a bit
more about how this
is utilized in some real-world
cases in a couple slides.
So the first thing
I want to talk about
is our assumed home- and
work-neighborhood analysis.
So the first thing
we do is we look
at what tower is
a device connected
to over a period of time?
In this given
example, we're going
to look at a one-week period.
In this image, we can see two
distinct clustering of towers
that this device
were connected to
during the time, the first
one being on the left
here and the second
being on the right.
The one on the left has a
much higher total time spent,
so we're going to look at
that cluster specifically.
And there's a lot
of research that
show that the time most
spent in a given area
is likely that home, or the
home is likely within that area.
So taking this
cluster, we're going
to place a polygon around the
initial tower with the highest
weight.
We then are going to
shuffle that polygon
across the different
towers to try
to find a closer representation
of where the home area is.
So we continue to shift this
towards the higher-weighted
towers until we eventually
hit that lowest-weighted tower
and get a rough
estimate of where
the home neighborhood would be.
From here, we
overlay that polygon
onto a set of polygons that are
based around Statistics Canada
information of where
neighborhoods are.
So these are important
neighborhoods
that are used in statistical
analysis of demographics
and what we use for
our market share.
So by applying
these neighborhoods,
we use an ST_Within
function to determine
exactly where that
polygon is, and then
we only store that
blue polygon that
is much larger as the
home area for that device.
So this again strips
away us storing
any of this information
that's really detailed,
and we go to this higher-level
piece of information
to just understand the
neighborhood, which is
used in that further analysis.
One of the big
projects we've had
come online since
COVID-19 started
is our Data for Good program.
Within this program, we're
providing governments as well
as academic institutes
access to our information
at the aggregate and
deidentified layer
to help them solve problems
related to COVID-19.
This could be things ranging
from how health care should
be impacted and what should be
done for health-care institutes
through the economic
recovery as we're
trying to reopen our economy.
We're doing this
under a strict set
of rules which are outlined
on our Data for Good website.
These include things like
these cannot be used for police
enforcement.
The data cannot be used in
any way outside of the typical
usages we have outlined
within our privacy policies.
We will not reduce any
of our privacy thresholds
for COVID-19.
We are staying
strict to everything
we've transparently given to
our customers going forward.
But this has been a
very powerful offering
that many of our provinces,
federal government,
and several cities
are using as well
to try to help in the fight
against COVID in Canada.
This is one specific example
of how this data can be used.
This is looking at
social distancing, which
was very important in the
early stages of COVID-19,
really understanding where
people are leaving the home.
So in these maps, you'll
see yellow as being
more people than normal
being out of their home.
As we head towards that
greenish-blue that's
in the middle of the
scale at the bottom,
that's typical
behavior pre-COVID-19.
As we get into the dark purples,
that is less movement behavior.
Now, I want to zoom in
on one specific area
to show a good example of
how this data can be used.
So as we're zooming
in here, this
is the area surrounding
Toronto, which
is the capital of Ontario,
which is the largest
province within Canada.
To the north of the map, you
can see these areas lighting up
in yellow.
This is a very
remote and rural set
of communities that are very
popular for cottage goers.
And one of the
things we immediately
started finding in the
data is that there's
a large volume of
people traveling
to these areas
from the big cities
to try to get away
from where crowds were.
The concern here is
it puts a real strain
on hospitals in these
areas that may only
have one or two ventilators
available at any given time.
And if there were to be an
outbreak in these communities,
it would affect
them much stronger
than it would a larger
city that has more ability
to handle within their
health-care system.
So this was being
used to understand
where to redistribute
PPE in order
to really help in
fighting COVID.
Another way of looking at
this is the public-health lens
and trying to understand
which communities
are interconnected so that
if an outbreak happens in one
community, you know which
other communities are likely
going to be affected.
So by looking at large
aggregates of how people travel
from one city to another,
we're able to start
determining linkages and how
closely linked different cities
are.
So this is looking at
three steps from Vancouver.
So this is taking Vancouver and
then going up to three steps
away and showing the
interconnectedness
of communities.
This can be used, say, if there
was an outbreak in Vancouver,
how long would it take to spread
to somewhere like Parksville
that you see at the northeast
side of the-- sorry, northwest
side of the map?
Or how long it would
take to spread to Hope?
What's the path of
travel for that,
and where would you see
other outbreaks happening
before you see it there?
And this can be really
critical in trying
to figure out how to stop
the spread of the disease.
So there's a lot of
numbers behind these maps,
and BigQuery is what
really makes this possible.
So we have 74 billion
records per month coming in.
We have 275,000 unique
points mapped out
to over 5,000 unique
polygons across the country.
There's 522 days of data
being used to analyze this.
This includes things
like building baselines
from previous years,
understanding the existing data
today, and going far beyond
that to try to predict what
might happen in the future.
And finally, there's
1.2 petabytes
of data being analyzed.
This is a massive,
massive amount of data.
And we're able to do this 25
times faster than we could
with our previous
Hadoop infrastructure,
and that's really the
power of Google Cloud
here is we're able
to do this just
because we have BigQuery GIS.
We couldn't do this with
our previous technology,
and we wouldn't have
been able to help
in the fight against COVID-19
without having the access
to this kind of technology.
And again, today we're
announcing our TELUS Insights
API which allows Canadian
companies to get access
to this type of information
through a queryable API where
they can build out their own
reports and analysis of what's
happening across Canada.
And to get more
information on this,
you can contact myself or the
TELUS Insights team through
our website telus.com/insights.
And back over to you, Chad.
CHAD JENNINGS: So, Joe,
thanks for joining me
in the presentation.
Thanks for announcing the
launch of TELUS Insights
in the presentation.
And also thanks for
the work you're doing.
It's just a really
great example of how
we can bring these
tools and this data
together to do good stuff
for people that need--
people that need
to understand this,
like public-policy
decision makers.
So I really appreciate that.
So to wrap up, everyone--
by the way, this
is the last slide.
So if you're tired, we're
just about there, so hang on.
But to wrap up, I wanted to talk
a little bit about the context
that we have developed
here at Google
around geospatial
analytics and how
we're thinking about all
the different areas of it.
You can tell a little
bit about this.
We foreshadowed it with
the rest of the talk
because we talked about imagery.
We talked about tabular.
So I just wanted to wrap
that all up with one slide.
On the left side,
you see the types
of data that frequently go
into geospatial analyses--
tabular imagery.
On the bottom here, there
are preformed data assets--
the Earth Engine catalog,
the Descartes Lab catalog,
BigQuery's own
public data catalog.
There are bunch
of assets that we
have just available for
folks to start working on.
In the center here, these
are the capabilities
that a wide-ranging
geospatial-analytics
practitioner will need.
They have to work on tabulated.
They have to work on imagery.
Maybe your use case
doesn't use one of those,
but we need to build it
out for those who do.
The bottom ones here,
mapping and data
visualization-- you
need to be able to get
your results on a map.
Otherwise they're
kind of meaningless.
And we need to be
able to bring to bear
machine learning and artificial
intelligence into this
so that we can do
predictive analyses as well.
Once you bring all
of those capabilities
together over these data
assets and types of data
that are shown here
on the left, then you
get all of these use cases--
so the ones that I described
earlier, the ones like Joe
described.
And it really is
our thesis here,
and we're seeing
this being borne out,
which is really
exciting, that once you
have these capabilities
available at the scale
that they're available at
inside of Google Cloud,
you can do your analyses
over much larger data sets
and do much more interesting
and ultimately impactful
analysis for your users,
for your customers,
or for the public.
So with that, thank you very
much for spending a bit of time
with us.
My name is Chad Jennings.
JOE BETTRIDGE: And
I'm Joe Bettridge.
Thank you very much.